alright hello everyone come back again
the Saqqara now we're I'm gonna do
another stream I think I'm gonna play
some maybe try and play someplace a
match it's got some people just just to
get it all going so I think I'm live if
I'm not live something something let me
know but I think I am live right now so
let's see
yeah okay so all right so I am watch so
let's see who's on willing to play I
think maybe I'll try and play some games
against this guy Dulles I think this is
this is a dubov I think it is let's see
if he accepts in games all the way for
everyone to come online since I think
it's showing zero yours opening so yeah
so I'm just gonna wait till everyone
gets in here get going
so alright so let's see so oh do you
accept oh they accepted my challenge
sorry I didn't okay so alright okay so
here we go so far pretty standard I'll
play CC for Quincy - maybe night PD -
maybe night seat area not sure place d5
interesting hopefully no PD - here
probably night bb7 maybe or c5 I'm gonna
grab a pawn here see what you see what
he has I think it's compensation it's
probably insufficient somehow but I'm
not sure so let's just see alright so
okay so good so everyone's here um okay
so I'll play hopefully Queen v1 here if
you take sell probably just take with
the night Queen c1 was also possible
it wasn't sure it was the best move on
so can't keep the comments coming I'll
wait for you guys just to all show up
here maybe this just isn't reloading
correctly um so yeah so okay so he soon
as being a deep thinker okay so he did
take Queen e6 wants played before but I
think I can just cast a fish before I
think I've Knight g5 yeah why not I
don't see it if you wanna pin I take c6
Kessie to play quincy for maybe hey is
he just gonna play clear out five so
I'll take the egg the Bishop of Queenie
for I can play Bishop f6 there a lot of
attractive options sir I didn't gonna
play the simplest though I'm just gonna
take and play a3 probably although I did
I did just give him 92 I guess with this
Knight c3 idea a little bit careless on
my part but see okay so please repeat
all pain idea 593 probably just works
you wanna be four so okay all right so
yeah Dulles is I think I mentioned
before is a Danny Doodlebug he's a
Russian Grand Master I'm pretty strong
player if I know I think I'll play b4
protect this knight on a five
everything's kind of solved now maybe
knight c6 and a move or two or work C to
work C one is always there I mean it
looks pretty much just like it's a clean
pawn here so this matter of what blocks
gonna do so you play the e5 so I guess
I'm a c6 he wants to go efore if I take
he takes out 397 92 th one looks good I
could also just play e4 I played Bishop
c6 okay let's see so it's the moment of
truth like just takes Knight c8 I think
I nineteen six he's probably gonna play
rook seasick so I think I'm just gonna
play something a bit more pragmatic
maybe should be seven not there should
be something that would be bad new yeah
I think I'm just gonna play knight c6
and if you want to take I'll take now
you too keen eh one
hey guess we'll see what he wants to
hear z4 here as well not that I expected
but he does have it so now I think I'm
gonna take on c3 cuz if he takes alt all
I'll check and take to work on CA okay
so he's gonna move his King I'll take um
I I think - I don't mix it up a little
and replacing people if if anyone wants
a bowl game against me though if they
make a donation I think I'll play anyone
and he wanted to make the donation of $5
in morale I'll play them one game of
bullet if they if they wish but give me
a second let me get back to the scheme
here try and try and win this I had to
go be pipes if I played a four I think
you wanted to play with c4 so here it's
very important that I don't allow any
kind of exchange there should be seven
it's important that you're on a lot of
exchanger works here but he just
wondered with a six now he's gonna be on
two pawns so this should probably be
losing someone says what do you say
someone says good call on 150 ETH
Chikara they're referring obviously to
aetherium yeah 150 was a pretty good
prize it went a bit lower I think I went
down about 127 at the I think 127 was
the bottom when I when I was checking it
and and so yeah so anyway Dulles
resigned so it went down about 127
before rebounding back near 150 which is
where I had gotten in earlier now I
think it's somewhere near 330 if I
remember correctly somewhere in that
range at least so yeah it's it's more
than doubled so it's been been pretty
good it's been pretty good suggested
who were interested it's a robotic
empire donates $5 now Ison he wants a
bullet game I assume if you just love it
on the chat just to make sure see yes
I'm also trying to play stuff a little
bit differently now keep it keep it
simple since the World Cup is coming up
soon try not to play anything to to
super serious defy belief I'll hopefully
be for of course a 583 cows was probably
Bishop III and play f5 hero just age sex
age 65 I think is what he wants so the
only thing I have six maybe go for this
one maybe keep working three also
available here so he does play c5 so I
think now I'm going to take and probably
just flip your face six is my plan
please 92 that's a good move on no plane
ith five
so someone asked someone am i leaving
for georgia a chest day
chest pain 94 hours when I'm leaving for
Georgia I'll be heading to Athens the
2024 so today's what 21st so three days
from now I'll be heading to to Athens
Greece it's one of the few places which
has direct flights to Tbilisi Georgia so
I'll be going there I mean it's staying
there for a few days before heading on
to to Georgia it's it's just very
difficult coming going from straight
from the state's to Georgia almost most
of the flights seem to have to go
through Ross show which is which is fine
but it's it's gonna be a drag and take a
lot of time an extra effort and I don't
really I prefer to keep it simple like
hands so alright so Dulles just plead g3
so when h3 he takes on f4 I take back
and it's interesting very interesting so
very interesting actually so if I finish
three he takes takes Bishop before Queen
c3 man who takes takes takes takes takes
what to do to do it or not I'm gonna do
it I don't know if it actually works but
it's too too interesting to pass up so
he's almost certainly gonna take
actually I think he just yeah yes it
takes all take or if he takes I can also
trade the rooks on anyone first maybe
depending not not sure so take so I'll
clear okay one or just takes I'm just
gonna take on our for first because when
you take that I've got this double
attack here on this night so you might
play were Kate first always possible um
well let's see let's see it anyway up
this if he takes first guys gonna take
on a for you plays Bishop before I've
left three so it takes on f4 I'll take
on c3 so now I'm threatening Queen g4
Chuck because this Bishop Bishop
protects the night here so I have Queens
you for for example but I think just
taking on d6 right away makes more
Suns then again this bishop in this
night they're not coordinating very one
I've always got this queen G forthright
with this attacking this bishop and then
he can't hold everything so let's see
what he wants to do here so I see the
song rights comment will trust bait
donate tequila for Hikaru actually what
is this Bishop e6 and I just take the
knight and Bishop e7 fish about four if
he takes an idea bitched about four and
he's just getting like mated on h2 so I
know back to the chat said will they
donate tequila to me um I haven't had to
heal in a few days I had a little bit of
tequila when I was in st. Louis I think
Roni and bought some tequila for some
people and so Gio has had some tequila
at various times so I'm gonna play
working to during again if you take 97
I'm going to have the same Bishop out
for Dragon I'm ashes turning this stuff
for right away now so Queen c4 okay so
I'm Way up on time which is a good thing
so I think now I'm gonna maybe maybe
I'll just Chuck Chuck on f3 or just
bring the rook away and I think I'll
just bring the work back okay no no now
that I close let's go Bishop g5 about
for page for and this this should
be pretty good so hopeful over key eight
now got to be careful here I'm not up a
lot of time acts on the clock so tonight
a5 of clean b-58 flavor key for so I'll
take Queen d7 probably a four or a five
and now I'm going to try to do something
over here
probably h4 as a move I'll just play
Queen g4 give them d7 if he really wants
it now community six just h4 always take
and I'm just gonna bring the king over
to te southerner if you lose the d7 pani
just loses the game so alright so yes
okay so let's this next game would be 3
if there are any issues you guys just
let me know like what the sound or any
any of that stuff um just just let me
know so all right so b3 5 play there
should be 2 nice 63 g6 Knight f3
probably Bishop g7 D 484 Knight d4 or
actually actually if some could remind
me I think it was was the the name the
guy who donates was ampere that robotic
ampair I think did he want a bullet game
I think that's what it was someone could
just remind me on that before I played
dollars like 500 games in a row okay
it's a defy I'll take I'll play c4
probably he'll take me of your queen d6
fish grade three fish bait arena he
wants to go for a night g4 oh let's play
Knight to c3 cutoff 92 Forks now the
bishop isn't under attack on b2 after
Knight g4 sort d8 I played a bishop up
three probably bitched about five that's
like Queen e2 this one put the rooks on
d1 + c1 and just harmonize my pieces
here basically does the h5 I think he
wants an H you for now
close play h3 cover this g4 square take
away any of these threats and we'll see
what his next move so he plays Bishop e6
logical liver of d1
it's Queen before now this one I forgot
about this one this could be a slight
problem so if I play Knight a4 I have
some issues if I play he's turning I
guess Bishop c4 or DC for probably both
are actual moves this could be a slight
problem so hmm
play E for also interesting a for DS 45
I think I'll try it why not what's the
worst that can happen maybe I'll lose
the game so I'll try c4 probably he'll
take on c4 I assume maybe we do
something else too
ok the place where he ate also logical
but now what is he he wants to do
something so now if I click Queen c2
he'll take on c4 if I don't want my
queen will take on e4 so I've kind of
just have to pick my poison I'm just
gonna play Queen e2 and kind of hope
here I mean this is this is pretty kind
of ugly to say the least
but maybe something good can happen so
play night at 4 will probably take on b3
I'll take back
so Roboto Roboto Empire says do you want
to honor one oh I think I think 101 oh
if it's possible I'd be simplest so
let's see so right now this is gonna be
Game three so after this let me play one
more against Dulles get to an even four
and then uh then up then all in all done
all play robotic Empire so I'll take
he'll probably take I don't I don't
think Queen Bee through is the bus
snoops now he's gonna be allowing some
night c5 and even though black is up a
lot of pawns he has really bad clean
side pawns here I'm guessing he'll play
would be five but that's it's hard
to tell so I'll play Knight c5 o take on
your seven maybe he'll play Knight e4
maybe maybe not
let's work the eight that could be a
problem so maybe I'll play e5 or maybe
this Bishop c3 even or just visually or
I have to be careful so Bishop c3 takes
is no good
I played Bishop b5 maybe I guess I'll
play Bishop e5 and takes rook a one off
rook b1
I'll play work a1 probably
McGann this is this is not great but
this it's still only one pond here block
strolling up on pond to doubled pawns
here that are not perfect so while I
check or take I think I just take and
he'll take I assume if he takes on c5 by
Bishop c3 is his god play like this and
now this probably should be a draw
Black's gonna be up a pot or I he is
this one huh I forgot about this one I
guess it is rookie sub and I forgot
about this no that was that was a big
mistake on my part so okay so let's see
so what can I do here at complicate
matters then I'm gonna play g4 take
probably Bishop t3 we're okay five
there should be 751
i blundered that one okay
that was a mistake Wow that uh that was
surprising is that lag was he just
really slow at the end huh
it was really weird hmm that was really
weird I thought um I thought I thought
John will do what was pretty fast so I
don't know thought was something some
loggers just just slow at the end he
really should have played that quite a
bit quicker than he did all right
probably they played before again I
would assume or d5 okay so we're gonna
basically play the same tune for the
Haas game I'll play Knight f6 again now
here P plays c5 I think I want to play
Knight chief for this time let's see
what he wants to so you play c6 okay so
you plays Bishop b2 but now I think I
can maybe place c6 yeah why not let's
see what happens here I mean this is
strange to say the least
but if you plays b5 I'll take on c5 and
now if he takes on c6 d3 is hanging
vc6 I'll take on D three rupees six
probably work C eight I mean I can't
can't really claim that I'm better here
but I probably should not be worse
although I did a lot although he does at
age three here a tree 96-95 Queen D for
still there is still very complex though
very complex so age three now don't want
to play Knight f6 I think I do so if 95
it's like Queen D for Queen yet I think
Queen D fours right now if night after
i'll go queen da so we reached some kind
of weird position since i mean this
probably is more or less just equal
actually for for what it's worth since
all these kids have come off on Queen b3
probably just wrote c7 the network see
something looks right takes and just
95 I can take or I can play like Queen
d7 I think I'll just take though like 94
it's probably just gonna end up being a
draw Queen C 4 I'll play Queen b6 f d1
probably worked da bar whoops okay well
that was a mistake okay
that was really weird
all right so okay so where is robotic um
let's it's a robotic robotic empire's
okay there he is um one minute okay so
something challenge I guess here we go
all right it's a good luck robotic
pretty standard so far probably he'll
take or play d5 and alpha 97 f5 obvious
pre-move should play e4 okay that's a
piece maybe he'll try c5 go for the
tactic that I'll fault that if I take
his d6 check but 95 that g5 tried to
play for f4 maybe she takes I take I
mean I really want to get a pawn to f3
now so he plays out three correctly I
just eat a four accidentally but
it shouldn't be a big deal so I'll play
94 um Heiser Jack thank you for the
donation he's a Jack I'll play you next
after robotic empire hates all take fish
about five I'm just up a clean rock here
so I'm gonna try and exchange all the
pieces off the board if I can or not not
all the pieces but all the heavies at
least makes the task lot easier in
general and bullet just wanna take
Queen age four I'll just grab another
pawn like Queen d3 as long as I don't
allow some Queen no six check or
something yeah big deal okay so all
right good game robot you just gotta be
a little bit got to be a little bit more
careful when I'm when you when you sack
some pieces I mean also it's important I
think especially in the opening to tip
to not own to not move too fast if you
use a little bit of time it's it's okay
but not not to move too fast
so hi there jack where is Heiser Jack
[Music]
where as highs are Jack oh there you are
okay there sighs her job okay okay highs
are Jack good luck pretty standard just
gonna play normal stuff again age six
good move to prevent night h4 probably
he'll go a for maybe not you should take
correct there G for I'll put h3 probably
he'll take or he won't
I'll please see for I don't know if it's
a good move but I want to really go a
five I want to go a five where the C
pawn covers that square so play Knight
e4 Bishop g6 will play Knight FD to open
up this long diagonal maybe five I'll
take probably he'll take oh he takes
with the pawn open I'll take on me -
probably he'll 95 Crocs so it probably
takes 93 just rookie three so he takes
I'll take free move maybe he'll change
Queens maybe not I mean it's kind of
hard here I'll keep exchanging clarity
for with this pawn and a three
especially he's got big problems
so hopefully Bishop before now I can
play c5
can take two I'm gonna take I'm gonna
try to make this interesting I think I'm
just winning in all these now I'm
definitely winning second because I can
create to pass pawns here I create and
they pass th pot and I'm gonna create a
path B pawn or C pawn over here so now I
will see five and each five and and you
just can't stop but I've got to pass
pawns on on opposite sides of the board
so um so yeah that's a good try Heiser
Jack that was a good game you actually
played I actually played pretty well
probably the mistake was playing Knight
h7 and then not playing Knight c5 right
away playing this Knight g5 it was
important to play four or they can go
back something this but it's important
it was important background background
background here to just play Knight c5
and try exchange Knights and position
we've been reasonably okay actually more
than okay it's probably just completely
fine for black in fact but after would
be a southern pawn fall and it just
became kind of kind of boggling
so what's they don't want to see now I
guess I'll played all this again and
meantime while I ask why wait I'll play
something again I'll play some kind of
Hippo setup this e3 d3 night PD - it's
something fairly standard see see how it
goes h5 I'll play h3 might maybe I'll
play it for a minute he's gonna play
five so I'm gonna play a three vish east
six now this gets interesting I'm gonna
try c4 here since I have opponents
recovering this be Foursquare I'm gonna
try to open it up a little bit so he
takes I'll take with a deep on and Queen
d7 I think I'll take on d5
and did my move go through or not
9594 if v6 I'll play 95 Queen e7
I'll probably just castle I think I'll
just castle
okay da I'm gonna play Queen C to play
495 h4 so he wanted to do something over
here if G for he wants to play off five
so I'm not I don't know if I like Queen
c5 but I don't see anything along with
it so he takes on if I take he just okay
if I take he just takes them out to a
choc oh I forgot about this so I'll take
probably Queen h4 this is a little bit
ugly now but hopefully it's not beyond
salvageable so I'll click Queen B five
fish page three I'll probably just take
the pawn on b7
so cuz a back sit chat okay so what are
you you took on a ch3 salt take on these
seven so 94 so he's trying to go over
some takes night a for stuff very
interesting if I take Knight f4 it can
also just move my bishop probably in
less time it oh but he can also take on
just take on g2 first then I take night
of for King out 305 very messy very
messy didn't very very messy so he takes
I kind of well I have to take I had a
for kangju one probably if Queen age
three night g5 I guess I mean I he might
have something like work be a here that
could be a slight problem but then I can
go Queen c6 Queen c2 and off three and I
Queen from c2 would cover this g2 square
also work b6 yeah sir if these six I go
Queen c2 an exactly what I said is
probably gonna happen with Queen h3 off
three please night each okay so if maybe
it's just going to force a draw here and
if I go King up three do I really want
to take that risk and try to survive
some kind of freeze a position hang out
305 24 work f7
I think a computer probably survives I
mean I I don't I don't know if I if I if
I would survive it I mean I think it may
be for computer it's playable but it's
it's too hard place so it's alright so
next game so plays out for says he's
gonna try and place about five early
probably most 187 and he'll play d5 try
to force him to play e5 or do something
Claire clarify the situation here in the
center at least right away
flowing locks are distracting me from
your place so beautiful okay
I wouldn't necessarily characterize my
hair is a flowing locks but thanks for
the compliment anyway okay so f5 so now
I'm probably gonna take yeah I'm gonna
take on e4 he's brought almost certainly
in a playoff six here and on f6 I can
take on oh he's just gonna play there's
a c4 okay well done although then it's
gonna take FF 6 so I can take if I take
on f3 takes on g7 so if I take on f6 I'm
gonna take on e4 and if I go Bishop g7 I
mean either I'm gonna lose right away
lose like in two moves here I'm
completely fine one or the other is
gonna happen I'm not sure which one this
is g500 play 97-95 maybe s5 or 95 I can
just actually just take the night
probably
so I guess we're gonna see what he wants
to say okay so I can take on e5 and you
can play Knight up six takes a scaffold
I think I'll just take the night and if
Knight f6 which oh he's not even a plain
ayah says he's just gonna play like this
okay interesting okay so now I will take
on d1 and play knight c6 I'm probably
he'll play Knight f6 here I would assume
it looks like the only logical move as
far as I can tell so I'll take I'll take
with the bishop on Castle and so a
recent position where I'm up a pawn
there no there no no Knights or Queens
on the board which is important with
this Bishop here so no no Knights or
Queens on the board which is very
important now I play night before you go
swish b7 so I'll play rook e8 so I can
play an IP eight or night before next
with one or the other so I think here I
will play a five and a night b8 that's
an IP is my I'm gonna do my next move
tonight the eight rook moves probably in
d4 Knight a6 is my plan as long as I
don't allow anything crazy to have more
I get made it over here it should be
should be fine of course work h4 is a is
a tricky move here so I'm clintonites e5
now it doesn't have our B force it's a
four is hanging so he goes King off
three I'll play rook b8 maybe play for
b5 now and a mover to try to open this
up somewhat hang out for I'll play h6
just to stop this King getting in or
something weird happening over here I
don't know what he's trying to do with
King out for maybe run asking the age
six maybe like like Nigel would do
something like that but I don't know
anyway I'm just gonna keep playing home
this would be five takes birth d8 I'll
play we're all player b8 probably he'll
take he ate out of the sound town before
now I can take play Knight a six a night
if b5 I'm gonna go night before 95
so yeah if I can get this Knight to d5
then this Bishop has very little use
anymore
ah so route d7 I play 95 who wants to go
Bishop d8 I guess in the 96 or okay 1
now if I play rugby it works see 795 I
don't know if this works but I mean he
might have worked d8 also but anyway I'm
gonna just gonna keep playing looks c5
and now I'm gonna now I'm gonna bring my
king close if I get get my king to d7
here
I think I'm doing quite well something
cuz again this Bishop here is not so
good now so I'll go kingi 7 I'll play
rook 8 and now I want to go R ok foreign
and everything is looking very nicely so
if I play ok for his king c5 that's like
work a2
so please work day six so I'll play up
see two can be for night c7 or for k7
King c8 if b69 p5 King be through Brooks
III probably it's getting way too long
times I just way too low so alright next
game I'll play d3 again try to redeem
myself you waiting for some more
comments and I'm looking at the child a
little bit as well case people are
wondering why I'm slow at times as I am
reading the chat just to see if there
any constant you guys have any questions
obviously keep keep them keep them
coming
thank you thank you at the at the The
Rock Twitter I think that twirler I need
my glass it's amazing how simple because
it's amazing how simple my explanations
are thank you for the compliment
so h4 I complete g4 I can also take
maybe it looks I'm gonna try something
weird I I don't I mean it looks very
weird to play like this but I don't know
if this is actually bad and I figure
it's uh it is online trust might as well
have some fun take some risks so Queen
h4 he wants to take on e3 so I can play
Knight f3 Queen h5 and play Knight up
for one also I think that makes more
sense of Queen takes h5 then I can take
on d5 words with the knight on f3 after
Queen h5 it it blocks a diagonal I mean
let this night here I no longer have
this deef Bishop takes d5 at the night's
hero vs. f3 vs. off one so so let's see
what he's gonna do
so he does take on h5 I'm gonna take on
d5 burp d8 now I have a couple options
here I could play c4 I could play Bishop
efore - I mean I think I'm just gonna
keep it simple and just take and play
like Knight g3 now Queen h4 I don't know
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna do something
but he's probably most certainly gonna
play clean th 4 here so no I don't want
to play clean i3 excel before I could
play e4 here myself which seems
reasonable
yeah I'll play you for here just as just
to fix the structure now my pawns are
extremely solid here
and basically at some point I want to
probably play a four and then just
castlelong
so he plays a for himself to prevent
that hopefully b4c five will take root K
five interesting interesting move so you
played Bishop c3 here I can play c6
maybe many many options I think here I
will not play that I think I will do
something I think oh here I'm gonna
redevelop my fish belong with c1 g5
diagonal I think it makes more sense so
I'm gonna play Bishop e3 and I'm gonna
play Queen d2 threaten Bishop g5 here
I feel like this Bishop and the Queen
here make much more sense than they do
on the other squares Supercross six on
take this open B file here if I can so
sudhi wants to do
because here biking is kind of open but
it's not in real danger not yet it not
yet at least
so Bishop e6 and now what to do no now I
can looking up one maybe I can also
redevelop my night maybe work before is
what I want to play that runs into
Bishop e7 probably so I think I am going
to play King f1 and give him this free
pawn here on age three and just scoop my
came over to g1
so take I'll run over to shoot one
probably Queen G for the queen g4 does
not actually a bath right here so I can
even play King edge to potentially not
that I will but it's yeah why not it's a
move it's a legal chess move now Queen
h4 probably I'm gonna have to go back
and you want to make a draw
probably but he plays King h7 so now I'm
gonna play we do one I think yeah I
think I'll play Queen you want to offer
a queen trade
now go King G 1 again and now someone
now you got his King Stach you go you
got like everything kind of all stuck
here against only so I'm gonna go see
for probably they'll go King g7 fd6 I'll
play with b5 I want to go work d5
so rip d8 I'll play like Queen d2 again
or not no no here I'm gonna take the
rook da I'll play like Tweedy to come
back
I've kind of bundled this a little bit
so I know a lot of rook f3 which was bad
he should to offer haha huh I think he's
worried about time I mean what's weird
is why he's so slope is normally a
Dulles I've played him a lot at a bullet
and he's usually very fast I don't know
why he seems to be so slow on
he seems very slow tonight for some
reason I'm not really sure why Bishop a4
I'll play e6 20 297 castles a 692
complain I have six here I think I'm
just gonna play b5 d5 Knight b6 standard
standard play in this position maybe
Knight f6 now just to make it
interesting cuz normally I just put the
knight on any sovereign and just plain
weird stuff but actually putting the
knight on f6 I allowed this idea with
Knight g5
I can play e5 here maybe I don't do I
actually have to take the knight that is
the question do I have to take the
knight or not if I take if I take it's
probably pretty bad so I'm gonna see if
I can play something else I'm just gonna
play Queen e7 here it goes back and I
want to counsel long just basically play
it a zone as though nothing happened
it's only a pawn I'm gonna stake here on
g3 oddly it's not perfectly placed here
because now it kind of keeps away from
over pushing these pawns on f2 and G to
forward and at the same time it just
gives me this time to do stuff over here
on the Queen side so uh he plays Queen a
5 out of play Knight g4 now rookie to
probably be 5 maybe maybe not maybe the
Queen up 6 is also possible I think I'll
just play rook e8 Sansa will move
and probably not six next is what I'm
gonna do so he goes Bishop c1 I don't
know what Bishop C want to actually
accomplishes but let's play Bishop h8 or
treat the bishop see this it basically
just see what what he wants to play for
here and maybe I can even go over
creating him over to as well
so although so queen queen there
Queenie one now I'm going to go c5
though and now it's getting a little bit
tricky so you place c3 so I can place a
c4 if I want I don't think I want to
place C for me I think I want to try and
rip this open somehow so I'm gonna play
b4 I'm gonna try to rip open this whole
Queen side C for d5 is also possible but
realistically it's gonna be very slow to
get this whole long like Queen side
attack going like it's a queen psyching
Xindian this would be five I'll play
keenya seven if he takes I'm probably
just gonna play Bishop eight or Bishop
c6 so Queen a five now I've got it now
I've kind of have to do something so I
play rook c8 when you take them on to
play work c5 and if there should be five
bishop c6 Queen eight three just Bishop
c6 I basically just want to play work b8
and try to harass him over here on the
Queen side so maybe 92 but 92 e5 is is
also not so simple so I will play rook
b8 probably Bishop b4 is his best move
here but again those are before I think
I can play night-night a4 maybe just
just try it trying to keep the game
messy basically as I mean this is
obviously quite bad for me but it's not
simp simple I would say for way to just
win
so again I've built up some time on the
clock introduced when I plays Bishop c2
which allows work to see for maybe our
work takes be for Queen before what does
this allow this allows something I don't
know what this law this law something
about their trip c2 so if I take he
takes I play d3 he takes by play Knight
B - ok let's let's see what 9tx b2 leads
to because I just want to play D through
with this huge discovery along this
diagonal when cakes on B - I'll go d3
so he takes rook d4 Wow okay 34 so now I
can take on d4 and play Knight c4 a
thing 94-94 Queen c3 right and now he
does not have a threat so is there
anything clean 893 then he takes one c5
I guess but whatever nobody cares and I
take and now I take the rook on i-4 oh
but he it's protected oh it's protected
oh no I didn't realize it was protected
oh that was very bad that was very bad
on my part
yeah I just just know I'm not gonna get
it done anyway I've got I've got some
chances here but this time I don't think
I want to draw this time I don't want to
draw so all right I played Jesus for
some reason I keep forgetting that
people actually play multiple wine it's
not always gonna be the same wine
okay so d4 takes I'll play Knight f3
Bishop g7 94 almost certainly gonna
happen probably takes takes I can take I
guess I mean I don't really I'm not
crazy about this but it's take and take
and Queen f6 Queen d4 probably takes
takes pretty crotch I would say well he
takes with a deep on and he thinks with
a deep on and he lets me exchange here
on the on the Queen King side so okay so
I'll counsel probably worked dat for or
g5 g5 l play e4 aged for maybe g4 maybe
each six not really sure which one he's
gonna favor
he favors g4 okay so I'll play 92 she
final play I'll play g3 here I'll give
him this pawn if he wants it he does
I mean he's he obviously doesn't want it
c5 play Knight a for c4
we play work III I can play h5 and I'm
gonna play age five here age six and I
think I'm gonna play work age four try
it try to gang up on this g4 pawn bishop
c8 I can take on and you take on c4 if I
want to I don't I'm not really crazy
about I'm gonna place c3 just provide
rip t4 takes I'll take probably gonna go
King C 293 knocks two moves if I got a
chance
so a5 king c2
see six no Chuck Edward III I basically
want to bring my work around and put the
night back on out for if I can these six
office tonight docked to protect the
pond at age five not I'm probably gonna
play for k1 or work e1 e5 e6 one of
these two ideas probably if he's gonna
force my hand then I'm just gonna play
e5 right away so here Ricky one he's
just gonna go rook rook d8 but I can
still play e6 maybe e6 e7 so place a
four so now maybe e6 makes sense here
but I think I'm just gonna take the pawn
no I'm gonna go be six probably this are
just gonna be a draw but I can one can
always hope
so alright so takes I'm going to take
he'll take obviously takes takes takes
takes I mean probably it's alright goes
king f6 he doesn't want to exchange the
rooks interesting if you can take a
Teague with the pawn possibly but then
then Bishop b4 doesn't really look very
exciting so probably this is just gonna
be a draw so I mean I can take or play
like f4 I'll try out for why not
try to make it more interesting more
dynamic not that it is but there are
more opportunities here for black to go
wrong if I can get the right kind of
setup here so it d7 hopefully can be to
to cut the rope from coming in c5 Knight
c2 fish about five probably night a
three fish b6 I'll play work e5 because
now I want to go night III I really want
to get this night to III and get the
ideal setup I know I get 93 d8 can't see
- let's start bringing I came closer now
okay one I'll play c4 she one
ooh work g1 ooh ooh that was bad hmmm
that was not the right way to play this
okay that was definitely not the right
way to play this okay so now I've gotta
focus
kingi for for chief 395 so I think I'm
going to trial you think I kind of have
to try this this isn't really what I was
planning on doing but I kind of don't
have a choice so I'm still gonna get
rookie so it's probably I'm not I can't
lose this but I don't think I can
necessarily win this either so I can
take which part I think I'll take this
one
and over this way and now go this way Oh
shucks now King Athena I'm gonna go and
I go age 6 h 7 96 and now he's probably
got himself into a trap again so I don't
know why he's so slow but but anyway
that's another another win
so next game before I'll keep playing
the same thing that I've been playing
every other game no reason to change up
at this point probably gonna see some t5
again we're probably gonna have
something very similar what was played
already he's gonna play d5 at some point
I'll try and tweak the move Ward just in
case and now I'll take just to see how
he wants to play this I guess he can
take on e6 though none take on c3 but
this actually isn't so bad this I kind
of like cuz there's rock on b1 unless
white can go c5 at some point doesn't
really make a whole lot of sense what
white is trying to do here cuz boy has a
bad pawn structure so I'll play um
hopefully Knight f6 here if Knight age 4
I'm gonna go rook e8 and I've got 4 I'm
gonna play Queen e7 oh dang eh 6 whoops
whoops whoops whoops hanging stuff
hanging hanging bishops there okay it's
not just folks I kind of just blundered
that pawn on him aged 6 but I think I
still might be okay after Knight ft7
because if he takes I just take on e4
maybe I don't even have to take on e4 I
couldn't even just play Queen e7 and
this castle lon
so any more questions in the comments
it's a tricky one okay so you well he
wants to take h6 but now see just like I
was gonna do before I'm just gonna play
Queen f6 and I'm just gonna go along
just to get out of any any danger here
on the you know it's my king and I feel
like already this is starting to look
quite good for me because again he's
kind of has to prove something right
away or else he's just down a pawn for
nothing because there really are no
weakness is in the black position here
so now I should just be doing great it's
night you two I will play not g5
probably maybe work off the eight fish
page six point out three I'm not crazy
about it but I'll try g5 go age five and
I want I really want to play g4 here and
just break up break up this structure if
I can it's a ninety five I'm gonna play
Queen g7 no I'm threatening c6 also to
fork tonight in the bishop so you guys
wish me to known to play g4 there should
be three I'm gonna take I'm gonna play
aged for now something I'm the one
attacking here out of nowhere like play
h3 just a white can't play h3 and
protect this pawn on g4
it's a g5 uh hey there's plane ID six
and just Knight takes e5 probably I mean
he has King h1 I guess yeah he doesn't
King h1 which I kind of I kind of
miscalculated this - no he isn't he is
rook to one so I'm just gonna play King
King b8 now I'm gonna play Knight a for
try to exchange his night off and open
up this long diagonal on the White King
so let's say so what do you do he plays
c4 so now I don't really want to take it
so I'm gonna play with DF v g3 I'll play
hmm I want to play Knight c5 here if he
wants to take you can take all the steak
with the D pawn it goes Queen d2 I take
no I'm probably almost certainly gonna
sack here yeah I mean he's begging for
me to sack I can't resist sacking here
so if I take he takes rook cheese fries
so I have Queen g6 also as a move I I
think Queen g6 makes sense to North D 1
now I've neither I don't have Knight up
to here okay so what do I have
90s g5 is a move I think I'll just play
Bishop CAA just threaten Bishop g4 now
as well and then these two rooks on f3
and d1 or are very loose also bitched
about 5 is looming too
so plays Bishop c1 just allowing Bishop
g4 that's not gonna get it done
please Richie one okay he'll take I
think I can just do I do I just go night
off to and Queenie for Chagas coming all
this start grabbing all the ponds so
King G one take 25 chocolate so okay so
I think this is probably last night play
guns Dulles for now at least
um again as I mentioned before if anyone
wants to donate I'm more than willing to
play them in bullet game so so for those
who are interested think about it
alright so we're playing the same same
line of the this um this the sarsen
again a zoo I think we played this
earlier earlier in this match to you
played Queen d6 and that that game the a
I'm gonna play I'm gonna play Queen d2
and I'm just gonna play work d1 Roxy one
right away as fast as I can
especially six and Playworks c1 but I'm
gonna play Queenie one here just
something different mix of flavor play
work see one maybe place between before
again I can play Knight a four I can
also just take I think I'm just gonna
take and try to play some kind of
endgame with with some some loose pawns
here on d5 and c7 if I had the chance
you can also play Knight e5 and then I
just take and I have an 87 Knight takes
c6 if he plays if he tries to grab the
bishop on v2 so some person eight nine
seven five says no bond cloud I'll think
about it I'll think about it if the
situation is right I'll I'll consider it
so as I much for if he trades it in
place Bishop takes b2 I had 97 Knight
takes c6 so he takes so I should take on
b4 yeah so I should take on d4 keep this
way I get the ideal setup of the rooks
and his works are not ideal here
although if he can get d4 then he then
he might be completely fine but with
these pawns 85 interesting interesting
move so now I can take on c7 he's gonna
play a four I'm gonna play work d4 try
to play positional just offer him in
exchange of rooks if he wants it if he
doesn't want it
oh well and he's probably gonna play
rook b8 that's the only problem with the
position here as that gives rook b8
probably so I'm also will see what he
wants to do
so he does play repeat okay so he
basically wants to play a four and try
to essentially force a draw if he can so
if I take he's gonna take or not hmm
I think I'm gonna take and probably just
just try to do something here I mean
probably I have nothing good
so d4 interesting so you please d4
instead of 84 I wasn't really expecting
next now I think I can play Bishop c4
yeah I think I can play Bishop c4 cuz
now if he takes on c4 i clear I play
weight d3 and if I take he goes e to
work e1 rookie for nifty okay snow I
take
so king of six so I should take her not
Irish I play vertices six a four and
then take or just play King up to it
probably just came out to have a four
I'll take I'll take on any six and play
rook c4 so I'm basically trying to force
him to take on c4 on make sure my king
is close to these pawns as well for any
possible King and pawn anything that
that occurs so it could be six so now
I'm going to take and I'm clicks before
to prevent any a fours b5 I'm gonna play
we're k4 just to keep the rope tied to
the pawn and now now also I can start to
bring my king close as well which is
which is important too so I'm gonna play
G 3 g5 hopefully h4 takes I'm gonna go
king out 3 I kind of wanted to play g4
to force my King back but I there's no
guarantee he's gonna play it like that
so now I'm gonna play chief or probably
he'll take I'll take
so you guys rook c5 so now I'm gonna
play work c4 and so he goes rook b5 so
now it's this tricky so I'm gonna take
before
I'm gonna go King g4 entrer zoogs Vaughn
him so for the problems he might be able
player could be four but I think they
can check and take on a five now yeah I
think I can just check and I can take a
five and I think I'm just winning now I
won king f6 tricky okay
tricky I wasn't I surely expected that
act that was pretty bad on my part to
not expect that so all right so let's
see so I think I think I'll stop for now
against Dulles maybe let's see if like
if if a mom wants to play actually I
didn't actually want to play with bullet
but I'll claim a couple games quickly
so he wants to do maybe maybe I'll play
for beef or something try and try and
complicate the position c4l play Bishop
e7 this takes takes 94 takes I'll take
between before so queenie 3 I'll take
ooh what is G f3 ooh that's an ugly nose
okay so let's play King f8 check this
pawn on g7 now I'll play play over here
on the on the other play for play on
against this pawn on d4 if I can't
although it may be I can't
maybe I just can't so I'm gonna have to
just play chess so I'll be 5 bad
ooh that's gift
anyway the three pods are going to beat
the two ponds here
so I'll play them one more actually I
did what I want to play them on actually
just like slow slow normal chests but
anyway we'll see
okay so please cd4 interesting be fun
play 9 c4 let's see one further like my
position here actually like we need you
to push page three coming now I'm gonna
take and play Knight b6 take the change
try playoff three just consolidate this
king side before you can open up diag so
he plays might be a so I'll take I'll
play c1 wait what is Queen b6 I'll play
Queen d3 97 91 3 just keep them making
it's almost whoops that was bad
so now this games not require some
technique so I'm going to be fast
and what's happening here have I gotten
disconnected
[Music]
what's going on have I gotten
disconnected or see gotten disconnected
[Music]
something's happening
so I didn't understand that at all that
was that was very weird was that I don't
know I don't know that was a server if
that was me that was very weird that was
very weird
okay so unfortunately it seems that
again it's just not possible to play
ball at unfortunate when I'm streaming
but fair enough that's disappointing
so anyway let's let's say so I'll reload
the page trying play Yakov probably that
blitz see if he wants to play or he's
not online anymore okay so sedullus is
playing now so okay so I'll just play it
straight up let's just what I wanted the
first was in an actual want to play
bullet so so so yeah okay so it's the
next game all right
so it's he's slower am i lagging or
what's going on here this seems very
slow so okay it looks I guess I don't
know maybe he's just thinking a lot I'm
kind of confused but anyway okay now now
the pace is back so it's just normal
normal game fish me too I'm gonna grab a
pawn here I don't really believe in what
he's doing so you can take a five if he
doesn't I mean I'm just intending to
just take on a three and then take on P
- that's my plan here place Knight VD -
I'm just gonna take and take and I see
four actually I probably should have
taken on on d4 first would have been
slightly better but it's a little bit
late now for that so how to make this
interesting open IV six
Queen 82 now I'm going to take on d4
takes back okay so now what will I do 95
96 as a problem so I'm gonna click Queen
d7 here 96 others play rook c8 so you
castles it's gonna play like BC X I now
I know I want to go d5 and just close
off this whole diagonal and now if the
rook on seeing instead of being he
doesn't have this takes b8 at the end if
I can close the diag so now I close the
dialogue with d5
it's officially five so I can take if I
want to I don't see the rushed us
anything I'm just going to play 94 and
then try to exchange some more pieces
okay so if you take some g7 I'll take
you can take 94 I'll take on e4 Knight
b3 and now I can take out c1 I can also
just play Queen B 5 maybe
Brooksie once seems reasonable but I'm
gonna play Queen d5 here I'm just gonna
try and take advantage of the
misplacement of his PSA hopefully he
grabs on any sobbing oh that would be
nice but he's my mom's not gonna do that
so night 95 that's really hard to do
anything unfortunate it's kind of like
cotton no-man's land a little bit song I
don't know if I want to take or just
plug a 6 and just play solid it's tough
to decide
I think I'll clear okay I'll try to keep
I'll try to keep it interesting even if
it's possibly just bad makes more sense
than just making a draw here so I'll
play up d85 my night before actually I
was giving up c7 I did but he missed it
so night night night c5 I'm gonna play I
could play e5 no e5 takes knight c6 is
no good so we're gonna play rook d6 and
if work a one I'm gonna play that rook
e1 I'll play with b6 I mean I guess he
has 97 now and probably I ignite now I
can't avoid a draw I guess but
but you know III don't care I'm gonna
I'm still gonna try to avoid a draw here
so or maybe that was a bad choice
actually because now it's gonna be no
I'm gonna have problems so no I don't
start trying to flag him so all right
Eric human thank you for the adone Asian
I will play you shortly trying to
survive this game first now six is a bad
no just give me four but okay whatever
now it's just seen office of course even
but after that bullet came I'm knocking
I'm not going to show me any mercy and a
flag and now
so okay so not scam yeah okay so after
this one I'll play air cumin at 384
again most fraught of reason everyone
since we planted the same opening
tonight just make me a little bit boring
but such as life can't can't have
everything in life I could take I clean
I see through I think I'll just all just
play some kind of an game I guess
mr. b6 I'll castle Cheney 7 I think
we're playing a 95 or Knight d5 Knight
d5 looks like the right concept but I'm
not sure if I have an advantage here
it's gonna be very hard to prove
anything so I have to be extremely fast
with the development here like so you go
to c6 so I think I'll go work a 5 maybe
or work c5
okay 5 looks like the clock move
so you're just gonna gambit upon here
which is interesting
I'll play Bishop eat or age I'll play h3
just to cut off this g4 square from the
knight place b6 hopefully we're okay for
probably night night f7 now I fish a 6
for example which looks pretty good
though you can then take which would be
7 or 58 so maybe e4 before then he's
gonna play before he would play a 4 so I
probably achieve four makes more sense
so he takes I mean I don't have to take
I mean I think I'm gonna play Bishop g2
give him the option to take on G first I
think that would favor me then this
Knight is less secure on e5 so please
work up eight don't play I don't know
what I'm gonna play here maybe takes
maybe not takes time for some
prophylactic I mean it's not a clear up
t1 just take this D file think yeah he
takes on g4
oh he plays 85 wow that's not what I was
expecting and I think it's a bad move
too
they working for
it's fun now I'm gonna go back to d4 and
now those pawns are all over the place
here so it's it's gonna be a tough task
black probably still once again
completely fine but it's not going to be
simply hopefully h4 try to get something
along this diagonal on these two rooks
so it goes work out six but now I think
rookie for gist or I play rookie for
player looking for work e6 maybe it's
not enough to win see it's gonna be
working six bishop h3 Knight g4 it's
gonna happen and now I have to figure
out I think this should still be pretty
good for me though so if King f5 I go
work out for if he doesn't go King on
five I just take the knight on g4 under
sub a pawn
although again as the old saying goes
all working fauna and games are drawn so
objectively it should still be a draw so
Ricky eight now I could play rookie four
but no it doesn't doesn't really do so
I'll take I'll take and the king of five
will play work out four and then King d2
King out seven I'll just play King do
two so I'm gonna throw on a Chuck
clicking do too
the five I'll play a four try to provoke
some weaknesses here on this this this
Queen side so be for all three for now I
want to go G five maybe okay five if I
can't hang out six health it whoopsie
for three and now he's in trouble
because now even now as pawns on the
Queen side are all too weak it's Ricky
for all those take the rope c4 c3
aknowledge this morning completely
winning because now I have too many too
many pawns we can install alright sorry
I still owe you a game Eric human sorry
yeah and I lied the Pope sorry okay so
lastly game last two games let me go to
10 even six since were four that's
always what I try to do just said
everyone is the same over black and
white so okay so after these two games I
will play Eric human and then I will
play Bligh the Pope and again thanks for
the donations from from both Eric human
applauded Pope so Ricky one d69 PD to
h6h for I'm gonna get in so I'm gonna
try to play aggressive shots now and try
to make a really interesting and spicy
this age six g5 try to try to really mix
it up with it it could just be a bad
move obviously that's always a
possibility but looks interesting
c3 opens your six
now probably Knight f1 is best but I
think I can play Knight f4 and this is
this is already dangerous this King is
very open I mean all I need is the Queen
on the H file in this could get very
ugly very fast
who is he five I could tick I can
actually just take on e5 if I wanted to
if I take he takes and wait can I just
take off three amply names for here or
something Queen h4 and then he is g3
okay so I'll just play Knight d7 wait
for him to play Bishop b4 here or health
to exchange on d6 I saw primo because if
he doesn't take them this is irrelevant
so he does play wish before I play d5
play I'm gonna go play I'll play a six
just to provide a bishop exchange I
think I have the time I think time is on
my side here or what's that time is on
my side well yes it is
tonight he show up the Queenie 7 gonna
Castle long maybe try and do something
over here pretty soon
so be for now be for it seems like a
strange move because I could play b5 oh
just shut it completely down but I'm
gonna do something I'm gonna keep
playing weird shot so I'm gonna play c6
I'm just gonna try to run my King to c7
and then use these use this openings
file objectively it's not it not a great
idea but I'm not too worried so I don't
care about this pawn enough for he can
he can have it if he wants it
I'm turning into Danny wrench okay I
don't know if that's a compliment or an
insult actually um huh I think that's an
insult but I could be wrong but anyway
back to the game okay so so he plays c4
so I don't really want to take I'm gonna
play like I don't clear cage five I'm
basically just gonna say you know uh
prove that you have something here if
you can't prove that you have something
here then you're just gonna lose to Rick
see one no I could play work hitch eight
I think I don't really I'm not crazy
about the position that I have here
honestly feels like some how things have
gone a little bit wrong but it's not
lost at least not yet so there's still
some some play to be had so before I'm
gonna take and maybe I'll play a four I
mean this is this is kind of ugly be
honest this is not this isn't already
envisioned cuz that's for sure so Queen
c2 all flavor case seven Loki one I'll
play work d8 he's probably gonna play
Brooks c1 the Queen e8
rook c7 is a move how can I prevent and
I mean probably I can't provide to draw
here but I should not lose this that's I
would say so
probably he'll just take on any
sovereign to make a draw it a seven
queen six Queens c7 but no he actually
doesn't take the draws please no he4s
hopefully be seven tanks I'll take
Queen c7 and now now I'll probably oh he
still doesn't want to draw interesting
come on surprisingly trying trying to
win
and Hari Shiva says I wish I wish I
could play I should be careful here so
now I'm gonna go Keaney seven I'm gonna
take a look I'm gonna take a gamble here
that I can survive this even without
much time on the clock
he's six rich c8 gonna be seven and now
I survived so he just kind of he lost
the thread there it looked like two bad
news and now it's just all over cuz now
I can split queen bee 5 and know you
might he's just getting checked maybe
here on here on the edge files pawn
enough for very important pawn okay so
one more and then then it's then that I
haven't forgotten it's Eric human and by
the Pope
see five I wasn't expecting to see five
from the one so I'll retreat the night
to finish development fish b2 next move
and on a castle probably work associate
will see one and he is b5 d5 both are
possible D fives more equalizing be
fives more aggressive now he's gonna
probably Queen B aid in Queen a and also
just say I'm gonna put my queen on a one
to work e8 is strangely I don't know
what rook e8 really does you know I'm
gonna offer an exchange of the bishops
there's ninety five all pink they night
up three awesome tonight
tree plays b5 so alright now it's gonna
get interesting so you please be 5 volt
take I'll play like the b4 just try to
play b4 a3 create a weakness against
this you know pretty weakness on b5 if I
can so Rick c4 I can take if I want to I
think I'll just play a three keep it
simple another day I probably would play
this differently I would take on c4 and
just try to with the two outside pawns
it's risky and I think it makes more
sense to be practical about this one
play Knight b3 try to hit him with
Knight a5 and a fork also I've got a 94
coming
Queen d3 2 like well a lot of different
squares here to play on
so close Rick c7 I'll play Queen d3 and
again now I want to go like 94 and hit
this pawn on d5 but if I can thank you
southern okay go play 94 and now this is
kind of worked out very nicely I mean I
guess he has rook c4 here and he's still
kind of okay but I still think this is a
white white is for choice in this
position
hey please d5 like queen bee to try to
do something along this diagonal tonight
f6 now I'm gonna go 93 again I'm trying
I'm trying to play for a 5 and C Phi
this do zero to ki square so queen c8
work d5 rook situ cleaning one Queen c3
was a problem so just 95 ghost King g8
I'll play Age 3 create a square stop any
Knight g4 or anything along these
diagonals so you guys Queens to 6 now
I'll play 25
now use the rocío Queen d6 or like King
f8 maybe and I brought hard moves to
play
so it goes Queen d6 so I mean I can take
your play Knight b7 I mean so you guys
work c3 so you've basically just sank
all I'll hold the sudden game although I
don't have to take b5 right away I can
also play the sneaky rookie one here
because he can't defend b5 by taking
right away would go rook b3 and I would
have to go for like a for over four
pawns versus three pawns endgame but
with this I don't have to now with the
passed pawn I'm gonna have this pawn
that's just shooting up the board really
fast
it's a 92 so that's a good move action H
is a very good mr. Rick d1 probably 94
look these rook B - I'm gonna play
knight c6 protect the pawn here also now
I open up the the you know just
this line for the rook to take on d5 I
think 97 allows 94 so maybe it's not I
can also just play d5 actually and now
I'll take on b5 83 I'll play rook d7 and
I da probably work a5 and easy holding
or not g4 got six I'm gonna play like
King G to my e4 f3 and he's kind of
holding something somehow or not f4 or H
forest or WA not age for sorry F for
maybe 6 g5 and he's just lost isn't he
yeah it looks like he's just just lost
tonight a for all take an IV take that
check and checkmate in one
da so okay so alright so let's see so
where it where's um so Eric right Eric
human I think it was the other he is
so I've sent off the challenge Erik good
luck Erik wish you the best of walk
maybe some plea for she's looked at
Kroenke sixes now I have Queen d4 he's
got to play the ugly looking out six on
page four try plate for age 5 + h5
himself but no no this g6 pawn the
harmony of the pieces here is very very
bad for block there nothing really is
harmonized now after 96 I'm gonna throw
them like there should be 5 track I
think let's see 5 flick Binay for Chuck
now there should be 5 now it's East 6
square is a huge problem for block it's
probably already just lost in fact it's
okay 6 I'll take a 6 was a good move
actually a 6 is the only one that
probably didn't lose on the spot so
that's that's that's that's good tonight
he's 6 I'm attacking the bishop and
that's a free bishop I think so just 96
and that's a free night on age 6
let's go clean out three I could take I
mean anything's probably winning so it's
not his Jill
all right so yeah I mean the problem
with that game for bought fur fur for
Eric was that he played Jesus when I had
this queen D for move and after that it
was just very very difficult to play on
it was more important to play Knight f6
first and then they don't would have
been all wouldn't have been great but it
would have been been at least playable
went there just lost on a spot so
alright so I was looking for where is
Bligh the Pope I don't see him online I
believe that was just his name I don't
see him on wine right now so maybe I
have that wrong but I think that's stuff
it was okay so the meantime let's see so
so Dulles is playing I'll try and play
or not this what is it every time they
turn out right now is bullet
unfortunately so I need to make sure to
put it back at three minutes okay so
I'll challenge black saw black flash see
he wants to play I think he's the
highest rated player online he's not
playing right now so let's see if he
wants to play
DJ's shoo ganja okay thank you for the
donation DJ shoo ganja I will play you I
sent out the challenge to DJ chigan job
I think I did at least I don't know
maybe didn't go out but I thought I did
maybe I didn't go out I don't know if he
wants to challenge me make it unrated me
that'll make it work no that didn't make
it work so
so shag and Russia got into where
something the challenge I don't know why
it's not going through
wait twenty people are challenging me
right now okay there it is okay oh oh oh
what am i playing Oh anyways this is ha
this is not normal this is uh okay well
so what is this so I've got six nights
and a queen he's got two rooks two
bishops and a queen so I'm basically
playing with four nights for two rocks
which is not a disadvantage so this in
fact I'm starting with a big advantage I
think maybe this is wrong
maybe maybe block suppose have two
nights to to start I don't know what
happened to DJ shoo ganja but yeah just
looking at the starting position
actually this is I'm actually better at
this start so I have four nights for two
rooks which means I basically have two
nights reached rook so in fact I'm
getting two pieces for work to start
which scene is highly unfair I mean I
probably would already have an advantage
but to get to business for a rook to
start as a it's a very unfair advantage
for me I certainly don't deserve that
I'll send a rematch to see what happened
[Music]
I'm being told by someone that out
actually the odds it was supposed to be
I was supposed to get a get 1/4 not I
was supposed to get night instead of a
queen so basically I was supposed to get
8 night or seven nights and against
Queen to bishops and to Brooks so okay
so let's see so who's up next then
where's blah there was another guy who
donated earlier why the Pope but I don't
seem to see him online so so let's see
so who's who's playing then let's see so
who's who's playing at the moment so
everyone else's dulles is not playing so
maybe I'll play dulles again or he just
started a game so all right so in the
meantime I guess in all a long waiting
for someone does not play on if you guys
have questions or something I'll stay in
a chat for a few minutes while I well I
see what happens between the other games
so let's see so it will are there any
questions people have
[Music]
okay Jake Lake Jay King clarinet just
donated $15 so I guess it will play him
then
JK clarinets will play him I assume he
wants bullet if if someone wants to play
blitz I have no problem with that either
but but it's just whatever they want to
do so someone has a preference
now why is my challenge not going to
right it's not a challenge jakey
clarinet
the challenge seemingly didn't go
through again it seems I don't know it's
my ratings to higher what's going on but
might be a formula issue but okay so
okay so here okay Jake Jake he wants to
play me with all its okay so let's see
so I am starting with what am i starting
with I'm starting with I am starting
with something he's whoops there's one
piece oh we are playing both though this
is not three minutes I do need to be
fast
so I mean I've got like I've got three
nights what do I have one two three or
five of right now about four nights for
a queen which is pretty good actually
it's very good in fact so let's see of
course I didn't start out with four
nights for the Queen he hunt wanted to
start so that that made it easier time
to bring all my nights together just
clumped them up together here in the
center of the board just pretend that
they're fantastic
okay so night a four this is very weird
these nights they're all I've never seen
a pattern quite like this where they're
all like they're all like one two three
one two three four or five all like all
together now it's got to be careful here
not to get his queen trapped
sorry I think he just trapped his Queen
the Queen is just completely trapped he
is no squirts gonna have to SAP he's
gonna up to sack on e6 probably and then
once he sacked in e6 he's just down like
he's just down to pieces
so this will just be winning for me in a
couple of those more Forks can V be
bullet under just donate $50 thank you
cam vbm no thank you very much for the
donation so I assume that he wants to
play odds to I will say you know people
want to play off there is nothing wrong
with playing odds at three minutes there
is nothing wrong with that either if
people want to play three minutes
because with one minute it is quite
difficult of course with with random
positions so alright so it was cam VP I
believe it was KN VP what was it what
was that Klose name
oh it was fur cam cam V qui okay okay
was for a blood bullet match against him
on okay um okay all right let me is he
playing he's playing game right now he's
he's not playing right now he's not
playing hurt oh what's going on okay
after this game well all plan
I guess this game just started but but I
didn't understand was with can V be
playing as was a mom play he well he was
playing game wasn't he okay soccer this
can I'll play them on so alright
I'm gonna just finish this one quickly
uh anti OB folk the game this wall so
maybe I'll play all play be poke first
and I'll claim on like did just we have
a suggestion for games or it's just how
many is it I've got a remember this
course is also this game is blitz this
is not bullet so like playing like 500
moves in like one second is not actually
gonna be lead to quick win so Queen e3
I'll play e5
de Fievel and I take see size probably
fish about 6.06 this e to multiply
queenie 7 and councils long and try to
meet him on the edge file between g5
maybe just night a for threatening
checkmate it's not easy to this truck
made in one eye is Bishop b5 how
unfortunate but this position still is
pretty good I mean White's King is very
weak I've got felt like this rook that
can come to g8 all kinds of stuff so I
can even just like take on you take on
a3 even as fish takes e4 look just
warning and that eh for just rook takes
h4 as is obviously although he doesn't
have three doesn't he after work she ate
probably but this leads to checkmate in
a couple
so we're Chi to work up to I'm done i th
three and that's all she wrote
so okay so can VP where's can VP he's
still playing so I mean I guess I'm
gonna wait for him to finish and then
I'll all I'll play him and then
okay so here we go okay so okay all free
standard so far
now if it's Queens - I'll play a three
probably well I did just hang something
here
I don't know if I should take this way
or not now I'm just gonna keep it simple
and play - but it's not a queen bee -
unfortunately that was not so precise so
I'm gonna try to play interesting shots
here
[Music]
Thank You Adam Barclay I will play you
shortly
okay before it's gonna take I'll
take seven probably worked d3 e4 takes
one
Knight b6 as a move I guess or couldn't
be sex no now I'm gonna play e4 play
like f4 and just try to kill him here on
these light squares or dark squares
let's see what he's gonna do
Bishop h6 is a movie plane 82 and a
chief for work f3 probably Bishop h6 for
this I'll play Queen c2 c1 no I'm just
gonna play like 92 93 probably work off
- and just like
maybe this stuff trees move h4 I'll take
obviously
so I'm kind of live with this game it
seems very no that was unfortunate just
hanging on for no reason but it turned
into some kind of good bad going away so
in fact this isn't so bad when all
sentence pollutions relatively okay
so so far is solved pretty well pretty
reasonable so what he wants to do is III
Knight takes 83 is pretty bad
Brooksie - isn't this just a free piece
on c3 yeah it is
I figure this out there seems to be a
problem with my screen
[Music]
this better I don't know is better it
seems not to be making a difference
trying to get it on this games like Anna
so I can reset the board yeah let me let
me figure out what's wrong something's
wrong with the board so what is wrong
with the board one second that's second
you guys figure out what just happened
one seconds
figure out what just happened
yeah something's wrong with my port
right now give me a give me a second
honesty I don't know if this is okay for
now or not let me see what I can do I
think for the moment I'm gonna
temporarily stop the stream you guys I'm
gonna come back in a second see if I can
figure out what's what's going on and
I'll be right back so just give me like
two minutes to sort this out okay I'll
be right back everybody all right
everybody I think I think I should be
back now um I think the board is better
I think it's better I mean I went so I'm
gonna I'm gonna try and play and see see
how it looks I think it looks better if
there is there's still something wrong
with ward let me know at all already
just a second
tonight at 3:00 Knight f6 we need for a
place C 5 C fives a little bit risky
here I don't know if I like it
I'm gonna if it's not um so this is a
screen I think is okay as far as I can
tell so okay just making sure everyone
that the screen is fine and I'll just
keep all skull keep continuing I think
what happened is because I was watching
can be peeled play his last game it
messed up the board I think if I'm not
mistaken I think it was something like
that so okay
that was a poor move on cleanup 5 this
bad bad moves bad mistake so I'm trying
to get a Knight to e4 if I can somehow
it's gonna be hard but you're gonna play
queen g4 and just basically give me f
394 immediately then I'll take it
Thanks
694 64 and play to King III actually
that was it bad
[Music]
okay that was weird
okay last three
now that's knocking oh it still it's
night if one sorry's it's not quite over
I thought it just over for a side ladies
night have fun
okay
all right so last one last one let's see
[Applause]
sobytiya Quincy five
all right you guys okay so yeah so there
was a little hiccup with the UH with the
lion in the middle but but yeah it was a
pretty pretty pretty good good set of
games I mean I gave him the one draw
probably I shouldn't have
what was that those like those like 10
games I was in there on my crazy let me
at least let me at least play beef up
one game since I still owe him a game I
think it was beef Pope was neither am I
wrong I thought it was beep oh you got
beep oh beep oh where is he why isn't
why is he not showing up when I searched
him there's something wrong with my page
on there refresh
say where is it be Pope
the mysterious be Pope somehow I don't
see him maybe he can just maybe you can
just challenge me directly be Pope since
I don't I don't seem to see I don't seem
to see the cbiit Pope when I'd want to
do the search maybe just directly
challenge me yeah maybe just directly
challenge me I don't actually see be
Pope right away I wonder why is he not
showing up says be Pope is not online so
maybe maybe be Pope needs to log back in
okay bee Pope's not there than fine I'll
play more I'll put more against a can be
beat
[Applause]
so anyway I guess I've gone parts on you
guys haven't been talking much the past
few games I've been focusing so much on
beating I'm on but anyway so this
petitions pretty messy both sides of
some compensation not really clear I
mean why should be better obviously but
it's not trivial either
so alright
[Applause]
so basically here I want TVs know which
way it's going to council it's going to
council Queen cider King side I just
keep trying to delay so
so all right so again I'm doing pretty
well here
another good position so we'll see how
he wants to play this Clint IH III old
play Bishop e3 hd3 i mean basically it's
lost because these two nights that are
way off sides over here so so again
pretty normal
see if this c5 maybe maybe a 625 Bishop
c3
and black and some big problems here
they mr. Dillo takes takes probably
Queens g5 between b7 and it's all pretty
ugly Horeb d8 no now I can play b4 Queen
b6 c5 and I just deflect the Queen and
he's just way off sides so alright now
that that I think was was definitely let
me try to find B Pope's and since I mean
I do OB Pope a game and where is B Pope
I keep searching for him since like Alma
game and he's nowhere to be found
yeah not fast 27 at 2017 asked me what
um who who do I do the who is best for
guys sorry I mean probably would be
Magnus I mean it should be Magnus would
be my guess I don't know I don't know
who also be Andrew is a good score over
a very long period of time roughly but
over over the short period Oh over the
short period it's not not so great so
alright so I'm gonna play YP if I can I
sent out the challenge I guess it wasn't
be Pope I guess it's Bligh P where's
Blackie I just had to challenge the
Blackie maybe the boy Pete can just
challenge me directly if there's
something wrong
I don't know what's going on
so okay so let's see so so alright so
who's up next let's see um I guess I
guess I'll since I don't see I mean I
guess be Pope will IP whatever he is ran
away I guess I guess I'll play um I
guess I will play Danya Danya or oh he's
playing now so I guess I'm gonna end up
waiting for a few minutes so I'll see
and in the meantime while he's playing
is there anyone else yeah it's yeah
Danny Daniels up next without without
doubt he's up next but he's playing
someone right now so I'm gonna have to
wait for a second before I play him
there any requests anything else going
on maybe I'll put some music on I don't
know maybe turn off the sound any song
requests me or I'm just gonna put some
music on maybe I'll just put some
something on turn off the sound for the
movies on flying blitz at least playing
playing a blank bullet I generally need
to need to hear the sound for the town
poker for playing blitz I don't actually
need to that much so maybe since I'm not
gonna play bullet anymore at least not
tonight
maybe I'll just turn the maybe I can
turn the sound off whatever me let's put
some music on rise what's it today was
what the Eclipse day right so what's
that mean it's time for some what's
what's the song of the day
I don't know I feel like Eric puts music
on sometimes in the background so maybe
I should put some music on - if people
have any requests
in the meantime play weed music yeah
let's work
oh yeah total eclipse of the heart was
one yeah there's also you're so van I
think I think that was the other one
[Music]
maybe I should get youtube bread in the
meantime
[Music]
- louder okay
alright I'll turn the music off since
clearly that's doesn't seem to be doing
the trick so I'm just gonna I think I'm
just stuck waiting for for Daniel to
finish this game so yeah so anyway that
was uh I know I've heard Eric put music
on it's probably just because uh because
it's not it's not background music that
it's just reflecting or something um but
but as I think everyone's saying there's
some kind of echo on it so I'll just
I'll get back to UM I'll get back to I
just won't play any music at the moment
sprays probably yeah I just have the
microphone I had the sound coming out so
it's just that um echoing okay so let's
see who's on wine Daniel's online but
he's playing he's playing someone ah
sure I used to the same thing again give
me one sec I just screwed it up again
because I to start watching another game
one second that's unfortunate
one second
okay there we go and I just this one
whoops wrong one one second and output
screen capture seconds
and
[Music]
pull this down
and actually a lot I'm sorry one second
about all this you guys
sorry I only do this during the live
strings not my intention on okay so see
us there we go again um okay yeah so so
let's see so who's um maybe Tori's
online actually Tori's a Tori's a pretty
good player to action Elly I see him I'm
gonna try and challenge him see if he
wants to play or Michael q2 d5 another
player those are the only guys about
2600 who aren't playing besides Daniel
but let's see if either of them wants to
play so okay so I sent out two
challenges so it's let's see so who
wants to play um let's see so who's
who's out there I don't think it's Tori
it's it's Tori 42 but it has like it has
like a Venezuelan flag I think or is
that that's Columbian has so maybe I'll
okay my favorite customers back for more
it looks like penguin so I saw
challenged him - let's see let's see who
wants to play
[Music]
let's say
well let's see so it's be Pope online
maybe I'll see if I can find him again
or Bly P or BP or whatever whatever
whatever is going by still can't seem to
challenge well I don't know maybe it's
so your challenge does not match the
numbers current match setting to me my
rating is too high or something weird so
alright so if someone keeps spamming or
not spamming but saying tell us about
Tancredi Tancredi Tancredi Tancredi
Tancredi Tancredi
Tancredi yeah I don't know who Tancredi
is I mean I've heard a couple of rooms
I've heard that it's possibly Dania I've
heard that it's possibly repor I've
heard that it might be grace Chuck as
well I feel like those are the people
I've heard of I don't know I don't know
who it is I mean I'm guessing it's one
of the few but one of those guys would
be my guest if I had to say um Kasparov
I don't think it's Kasparov I I doubt
that somehow it doesn't seem quite right
let's sit come on where is everyone
I need to play someone soon being maybe
I'll play this fishery fishery asel
fishery you sell fish our fishery
ourselves what is it he is let's see
I'll play him too he wants to do
or not maybe it's just not there right
now um uh yeah so okay hmm
all right so okay so here he actually
moved in t he did move yeah okay so okay
93 there should be seven d-46 probably
more of the same
Jesus is slightly inaccurate I mean I'm
just just trying to get to my basic side
up here brother played d6 first but it's
just a standard setup anyway but h6
maybe they'll take Bishop e3 up
hopefully g5 96 like I've been playing a
lot of games so far well fine I teach
for slightly strange move maybe it's not
very good but it looks interesting at
least play Knight of six probably Knight
c3 backhand and now I've gained
something aliso c4 just hanging you
forking that was a strange decision so
I'll play a 5 then I just want to go
like rook e8 and do something do some
damage long as this long diagonal the
King on g1 of the and the pawn on g2 so
ok 94 oh I'll get greedy there's no
reason not to be greedy when there's
material out there to be had
although this might not be quite right
so knocks now I can take on d5 and I
feel like I've done something rather
long here because he might be able to
just take and sack on e4 and this could
be kind of dangerous it could be very
dangerous in fact but we'll see so Ricky
for King g7 at least I always a king c8
here if I need it now I can place c5 and
if cleanup 5 will go king c6
so probably will retreat the fish back
to like c3 or whoa what is b4 Wow
what is before could be a very good move
so b4 I'm gonna go King c6 just got my
King out of the out of the line of fire
so Ricky one does not create an actual
it's right so I think I'm gonna play
rook c8 and if he takes I'll still take
back and all the truths when I came back
to b7 and maybe I'm okay maybe I'm not
okay I mean this is this is very very
sharp but I do have okay now I should be
fine now that I can get my King out back
into this corner where it can't be
attacked and I have a light square
bishop piece of darts for fisherman
if I get my King to eat for example he
can never really attack it so it's so
safe in fact that's exactly I'm gonna do
it's like I can put the King on e8 and
put a bumpy's seven there really
can never be any danger so things are
looking out the gun to a four I'll play
rook f8 although I did given rookie 7
maybe so now Queen d3 I think I can take
up five and his team because it's g2
pawn is so weak that I think I'm doing
pretty well here
okay so I guess he resigned he did rely
on okay so all right let's see so I
think I will play this guy how many more
I'll play him I think formula I'll plan
for more games than I think I'm probably
miss awfully thinks it's getting a
little bit a little bit late here now
and I do have to kind of try to get on
this get all the times and slowly for
your Europe which means like it's like
three third morning right now so it's
kinda like try to get on the time zone
before the World Cup so just a couple
more and then I'll probably stop for the
night it's 95 then 84
eight six I'm gonna click age three take
away this G for square if I ever want to
play like a four or something it's not
right at the moment but it is a positive
possibility eventually so 97 Oakley
would see 195 or fd1 probably he'll play
94 not guaranteed but probably
sufficient d7 Oakley bitched about 3d8
I could play b4 here but I think I want
to play 982 instead just try to keep the
tension position now b4 is very
interesting but I think I'll just play
Knight g3 a five solid solid move I'll
play fish 2 8 3 try to do something
create do something against the slight
weakness on d6 eventually that's the
plan
so age six and now I have to come with a
so then I'm gonna play Queen c2 T
because the night on g3 prevents fish
about five there the he doesn't ever
have fish about five at least not yet
so I'm track weensy tuna probably has
double the Brooks on the D file as the
planner here he's definitely gonna play
aged four and I'm gonna play like ninety
four probably or an eighty two most
likely I'm gonna go ninety four and
force him to make a decision with these
two nights here oh but he has bitched
about five that actually whoops Oh again
see it he had bitched about five I
thought he could only take with the C
night first and I would be able to take
out six with Chuck the way he played it
it's now it's looking good rook D ones
coming d6 is very weak eh for is okay
but not perfect
so there should be six I'll play Burke
d1 try to put pressure on d6 probably
they'll go Buffy
I'll go Bishop b2 try to use this long
diagonal Bishop g7 I'll take play Queen
c3
it probably plays off six or now he's
gonna it's gonna play King g8 which now
goes make clean off six now there were
there problems because now I'm in now
all now all his uh haunt seemed to be on
like the wrong square or somebody so
Bishop c4 is a move and not just I do I
want to take c6 or do I want to take g6
taking Jesus is much more double as
you're saying you can take b3 and we're
gonna put with both of us having a lot
of pots and opposite sides and with this
I thing I just end up up one pawn and
there's no risk whereas in the other
line there is some risk so rip b7 all
the roots III and he does of this
weakness here on h4 - it's worth noting
so I'm gonna try to bring my King over
as fast as I can
I said but now I work c5 you go scream
g6 and we're back in this end this this
infamous and game is four versus three
that realistically is very hard to win
because far I did lose at one time
against Pickett I believe it was some
some years ago
but now let's see now I'm getting what I
kind of want which is something like
this if for a for if you take sky play
e5 f three takes there's not so trivial
something so he goes can have seven but
now I think king of five is winning here
okay five I'm working at five I just
block with E 5 + GF 4 I just take out
sex so now I can play rookie 5 I think f
e5 s FD 5 solicitors rookie 5 simplest I
think rook takes d5 has to be simplest
because I can take on g5 and play rook G
for rookie foreign or kkh force Iran is
just winning and now I can play workup
for and now it's just winning kg for
so alright so start it's also kind of
like some kind of weird names Oh again
although I might not play it like your
names up here
oh so this would be to night of six
probably a three or III I'll council
probably this would be three or he's
gonna do it this way now Queen c2
followed by Bishop d3
so someone just asked do I know how to
checkmate with the rook I hope I do I
mean it's uh I don't know checking over
the brook I'd be a little bit a little
bit concerned about my level of trust
playing these days so anyway so far
that's pretty pretty pretty pretty
normal probably f3 is what he'll do is
you know I'm gonna play for e5 or do
something on this diagonal I'll play
over p8 and probably play for e5 and
remover too or just play work f6 work g6
like a caveman I think that that's
that's like the caveman style that works
sometimes but it's not my preferred
style to be form play Knight of 6 is c5
I might play Knight e4 I'm not sure but
why not
what could possibly go wrong after 94
because take who plays f4 so I'm gonna
play fish basics keep my Bishop Act it's
now it has a nice healthy diagonal here
actually I got to be careful not to play
Bishop i-49 just lose and I'll play e5
probably he'll take on b6 I'm guessing
or d6 it's actually the same thing
either one he takes it's gonna be lead
to the same position so he takes on e5
salt egg so it's obviously gonna take on
p6 now place queen g3 all take on a 4k
on g6 and play work d8 now it's it's
still very draw of course but there is
some potential here with with the with
me having an active rep against his
passive one
so Rick c6 and I'll play g5 if he takes
I play work takes the e3 and I back
Rankin so g5 probably has to play g3 no
I'll take 36 know how to play this I
mean I really want to do so I'm gonna
play work 8 - because if he takes before
I go there should be seven
he takes g5 I think I can come with
B - maybe or actually what is this
actually no this is just stupid I just
hung g5 for no reason this actually is
gotten very unpleasant because nice this
g6 moves it's very annoying but if he's
gonna play worked a c4 and give me all
kinds of stuff like okay so let's see so
take stakes begun this is still very
varied rosh i have to say but i mean
maybe it's possible to do something so
bishops you won a six it obviously takes
losses to Bishop c4
so probably something like b5 kingi -
this probably is this is just a draw was
croc play but I'm not gonna take it all
here
so it's let's let's see what's gonna
happen so they're all check t3 I'll play
Bishop b5 all the knives kimchi for now
as you saw it so yeah that's unfortunate
I don't know if I'll try to fly or not
but probably
there really isn't much point to playing
on but
yeah this is just stupid that's enough
that's enough for tonight I don't really
feel like playing anymore so that was
its guy doing this stuff so yeah I think
that's good that's gonna be enough for
tonight oh and that's just kind of
annoying so alright so I think I'm gonna
stop them for the night so so yeah so I
think yeah I hope you guys enjoyed this
trim a little bit annoying at the end
but or actually I actually I just wanna
sort of the common be Bly Pope is here I
mean I tried to challenge him once
before let me see I mean I'll try one
more time I just tried again I can't
seem to challenge him so I mean if he's
still there and he wants challenge with
me he can
but I don't
I don't I don't I don't I don't see him
so so yeah so I mean I guess I'll I'll
challenge him next time next time I see
him it's I tried it says waiting for he
Karl why doesn't it show up but I don't
see the challenge yeah I just don't see
the challenge unfortunately it's I just
don't see the challenge showing up so
okay so I think then what I'll do is
I'll figure out what's what's going on
with Bly Pope and I'll keep that in mind
for next time I stream that might be
tomorrow that might be two days from now
I'm not sure but but anyway all all
probably actually why are Hennepin just
a switch what's your stream schedule
Anka um probably I'm gonna do one more
string either tomorrow or on tomorrow is
Tuesday right I think yeah tomorrow is
Tuesday so either tomorrow on whose like
Tuesday evening like 5:00 p.m. or
something or on Wednesday probably
Wednesday evening one other two one of
those two evenings I'll do something and
that'll probably be it till until after
the World Cup but anyway one of those
what tomorrow are the next evening I'll
do another stream that that's that's
that so alright you guys so I think I'm
gonna check out for now so I hope
everyone has a good evening and I hope
you enjoyed the games and until next
time signing out it's a good night